the libertarian party has decided to get
woke and of course
they're backpedaling ladies and
gentlemen i bring you now to joe
jorgensen
uh she tweeted it is not enough to be
passively not racist we must be
actively anti-racist black lives matter
vote gold
well following this tweet there was a
major backlash
from basically everyone she got ratioed
of course a bunch of
internet social justice warriors were on
board with this
but telling the libertarian party that
you must actively do something
is like kind of the opposite of what the
libertarian party is supposed to do
what's her middle name is it karen it
should be if you find out it's
karen i'm going to die you know i'm
sorry i have to do this
my friends i give you the ultimate meme
and there it is
it's going around for a while right this
is super old but it's it's it's perfect
so i want to make sure it's clear as we
start this segment when i criticize the
libertarian candidates
it's not unique to joe jorgensen or the
current
uh party leaders because this meme
for those that are listening shows a
beautiful
majestic fox for which it says
underneath libertarian
ideas and then the next image is this
weird scraggly muppet looking thing
it's a dermadeed taxidermy is that what
it is a terrible
terrible terrible libertarian candidates
and it is a sad reality
that the libertarian party just for some
reason can't get a strong cannon now
gary johnson
you know he was probably as good as they
could have gotten in a long time
and then he had his aleppo moment among
other problems
so let this be my to be fair disclaimer
the libertarian party is not known for
putting forth
the best candidates now why can't they
do it i just don't know
i just don't know and i'll tell you what
so the second tweet
joe jorgensen sent out after the massive
backlash
was black lives matter means standing in
solidarity with a morning black
community
as we fight together to end qualified
immunity police brutality
sentencing sentencing disparities and
the war on drugs
not support any organization by that
name
this is an overt and outright back pedal
for one reason
calling for people to be anti-racist
saying we must
look man part of the criticism they're
getting is legit
the libertarian party saying they're
going from don't tread on me to
we must tread so naturally people are
going to be like yo don't tell me what
to do
but anti-racism has an overt philosophy
more more importantly they've actually
tweeted this out which
count contradicts what their actual
actual goals are
libertarian in chief this is todd
hagopian
he's a 2020 oklahoma corporation
commission candidate libertarian
activist
chairman of the northeast oklahoma
region lp successful businessman he says
and in this 3.5 rights and
discrimination from the from the party
platform
they straight up say that we reject the
idea that a natural right
can ever impose an obligation upon
others
to fulfill that right let me break this
down for y'all
the libertarian party has just asserted
you must take action uh to fulfill
positive rights positive rights
specifically mean
that you must do a thing to fulfill it
versus negative rights where you can't
do a thing
libertarians typically believe for the
most part in negative rights like
if you have a negative civil right it
means no one can
infringe upon your civil rights a
positive civil right means you must take
action to fulfill and guarantee
so this is where the big problem comes
in when
anti-racism is quite literally an
ideology
that says you must be actively conscious
about racism
ending racism taking actions to end in
inequities in daily lives
and it specifically refers to actions
white people must take
that everyone else mustn't just like
they're doing in seattle right now all
white people
need to go take this anti-racism
training you know about this
boom only only white people though yep
only if you're white and they tell you
you have to undo your whiteness
so i'll be i'll be fair maybe joe
jorgensen did not know what she was
talking about
i'm definitely not but maybe then she
should tweet out i didn't know what i
was talking about and that was a mistake
but she doubled down
but she doubled down anti-racism you can
look this up it's not
a a new thing like that it's an ideology
that's been held
for a long time it's like if you say you
oppose racism
that is different from being an
anti-racist like i think racism is bad
i believe i personally land on the side
of
i think businesses should accommodate
the public
and should not be able to discriminate
for a variety of reasons because i am
not a libertarian i'm a liberal meaning
i
typically believe for the most part in
liberty but there are some things where
i agree
we have to figure out how to work
together and sometimes you got to say
listen
you know to give you this specific
example i'll try and make it simple
because
you're probably gone for too long if you
are in a public place
funded by public funds and public taxes
i understand some people don't agree
with taxes
but for the time being if i'm putting in
my money for
the roads the electrical for the
plumbing the infrastructure the police
the fire department
the national security then i don't think
it's fair that you get to benefit from
my contributions but then deny me
services when you're using
infrastructure
that's kind of my position so i do think
there's an argument there if you're in a
more rural place
unincorporated or something or you have
a private business or you have like
a consultancy or something it my
position mostly falls upon brick and
mortar
and like the use of public places but
for the libertarian party they don't
think businesses should be allowed
i should have to adhere to any of this
stuff so that brings me to
i believe this is yes michael malus
i tweeted i think michael malus just
shattered the brain of the libertarian
presidential candidate because he asked
as the libertarian candidate for
president do you support
the repeal of anti-discrimination laws
she didn't answer because if she does
and she answers what she really thinks
the liberty then she would get torn up
they just boxed themselves into a corner
and i gotta say it really does feel like
they're not i'm sorry man they're
they're
they've just done themselves in i think
at this point you we are going to see a
massive number of voters
flock to donald trump i don't know hold
on hold on before we move on from that
at the same time
didn't they just in cal in california
right yeah didn't they
like change their civil rights um so you
can discriminate
so almost that is very libertarian of of
california
right arguably yes right so it's like
she almost
it almost feels like she's just
pandering to that crowd now well obvi
obviously she is but it's you know it's
like specifically
about the rights and discrimination it's
like that's what they're doing
in many of these places they're allowing
people to discriminate again
so maybe that's what people want maybe
they
maybe that would be um i don't even know
what the answers are going to be but
it's like
it seems like she's uh she is pandering
to them and it's working
it is for some so if we now have the
democratic party
but not the libertarians the
libertarians are pissed oh i know
right so like so so here's what i'm
saying right check this out this is
2016.
gary johnson got 4.488 931 4 million 480
931 votes this is after the aleppo this
is the results okay yeah
right so how many of these four million
first of all will actually hear
that she tweeted out support for black
lives matter i heard it
you're you're acting on twitter i voted
for yeah well i voted for were you
planning on voting for the libertarian
party
i will not tell anyone who was even
thinking about voting for because i
don't know yet
i was considering it yeah are you now no
yeah absolutely
that's not libertarian how could you say
something like that it's the opposite
telling telling people what they must do
i'm like i don't like it
yeah because the way i think about it is
for the libertarian for for the
libertarian party
you're it's like libertarianism
acknowledges that other people believe
other things
to tell someone what they must do or
believe is the antithesis of
libertarianism
like yeah i don't like anyone telling me
what to think or believe
i i don't like it at all i i have the
right to disagree with you you have the
right to disagree with me
we can talk about it civilly i'm cool
with that that's how i roll
so now we have the democratic party and
the libertarian party
and they're they're they're embracing
intersectionalism
now i wonder if they'll try and
backpedal on this because they're not
going to win
support from progressives that's insane
what do they think was going to happen
that like antifa is going to be like oh
hey that settles that i'll i guess i'll
vote for the libertarian party now
because they believe in like i guess
because they agree with them on police
brutality stuff
antifa is like the the attack dog of the
democratic party
it's like that's i mean i'm maybe that's
not
a fact but that's just what i believe
that's what i'm seeing
they're not going to go libertarian
they're going to vote for democrats
because that's what they were told
no antifa hates democrats really but
they would vote for bernie if bernie was
a democrat uh okay
now that joe biden and bernie have done
the unity party thing
you might see a lot of these people be
like i'll take it like take take take
the take the concession because you'll
get some wins i mean are they going to
be on the ticket this unity
party so no all right it's not unity
party
it's actually really funny that you know
brett weinstein did the unity party
thing and then joe biden and bernie
announced their unity platform
to unify the progressives and the and
the corporate damn unity platform
well basically what happens is they're
not advocating for
directly for medicare for all they're
advocating for a path
to medicare for all but they're
advocating for a strong public option
that would
automatically enroll low-income people
into a
deductible-free government paid health
care program which i'm like
huh sounds like medicare for all yeah so
it's basically like saying if you're
poor free health care if you're not poor
suck it up and pay for it so here's what
we look man
you know what i can't help but be a
little pessimistic
you've got the libertarian party
embracing this stuff
oh man everything is broken you know we
had that story of the the nbc guy who
claimed that he had covid
yeah then it came out that he just made
the what he made the whole thing up no
no i read about it it wasn't that he
didn't er
he was sick but he was just saying oh
i've got kovid i've got kovid and it
turns out
no he didn't it was just regular
pneumonia which exists without kovid
and that's what it was so they blew it
out of proportion probably the same
thing
yeah combo i mean he probably didn't
even have any sickness because
i don't believe anything that comes out
of that man's mouth he got food
poisoning and it was like
coven here's my chance let's extort this
he ate a soggy burrito from the back of
the fridge
got sick and was like oh what do i do no
more likely he stubbed his toe
yeah walking up the stairs ah and then
he looked and then he looked at the
the bump and said oh covetous covetous
yeah covent toast is a real thing for
those who don't know like you people are
getting blisters on their toes and stuff
weird but listen here's here's how i see
it
if if the libertarian party just made
the like this is their aleppo moment
this is seriously the aleppo moment for
the libertarians
i wonder if because gary johnson had the
aleppo moment
i uh they may have already lost some of
these votes
and i don't think libertarians are
guaranteed to go republican
i think they're just slightly more
likely because they might take like
i guess i'll accept some things they
offer yeah
but most of the people i know who are
the libertarian party
are like socially progressive in some
ways
but it's it's a unique thing it's it's
own thing i don't think they'll go for
the democrats because the democrats are
authoritarian
big government and ideological mm-hmm
but here's what here's what i think
gary johnson's aleppo moment for those
that are not familiar was when he was
being interviewed
in 20 it was like it was a 2016 cycle so
it might have been 2015.
he was asked what he would do about
aleppo and he said and what is aleppo
and for those that don't know it's a
city in syria that was being you know
under siege isis and all that stuff
and everybody like in the politico
sphere was like
what this dude's running for president
and and then so they had to explain it
to him he went oh
oh yes syria oh okay well and that was
like a
huge gaffe for them i gotta i gotta be
honest though that probably generated
the dude a ton of press
people who didn't know about him before
all of a sudden were like well i'm not
gonna blame him for not knowing the name
of that city but i'm not gonna vote for
him
well some people probably were like i'll
vote for well four mil four mil
four point four eight eight right yeah
so here's what i'm thinking man
the endorsement of black lives matter
and the call to direct action
that i think is to cost them bigger than
they
i agree i definitely agree with you i
think
if if you went to every single person
voting libertarian
95 would walk away upon hearing she did
this i could be wrong maybe people in
the comments will be like no no that's
fine we love what she's saying but i
really don't think so i'm not seeing a
lot of that
no people are on twitter not on twitter
no the libertarians are like
i have yet to see anyone that that likes
that she said that
well the left does i'm seeing like i'm
sure i'm seeing antifa be like here here
we won't vote for you but thanks for the
endorsement
right people are pointing out that like
if you actually look up
anti-racism it is it is this
intersectionalism ideology
condemning white people like you
mentioned in seattle they're doing
trainings where white people are being
told to undo whiteness
that just blows me away it's like
instead of letting racism
die off they want it on the forefront of
everybody's mind
and that's that's the opposite they're
trying to perpetuate it
they don't want it to go away they want
to be able to have this tool
to use as emotional like an emotional
trigger for
for people nowadays like i've been
recently researching so much
about racism nowadays you know and it's
like
it really is not it's not as prevalent
as they're making
it out to be it's not can we it just
simply isn't can we create an ideology
and movement based on terry crews terry
cruz's ideas matter
he's great great yeah terry cruz's ideas
matter
so for those who don't know terry crews
said like i don't care about the color
your skin basically you know
good people of all kinds we got to come
together yep he said he said we can't we
can't have black lives matter become
black lives better and he got attacked
for it
and then don lemon even was like you
walked into this you should have known
and he's like you should have thick skin
i've got thick skin look what i've got
and it's like
okay well you were saying the exact same
things that terry crews was advocating
for
seven years ago actually whoa whoa yeah
you're right right
way worse i didn't even say anything and
you're like wait i know way
way worse things terry was calling for
equality
saying like let's just all be equal
let's let everyone come to the table
have a conversation
don lemon that was not what he was
saying he was like pull your pants up
like he's his words i know verbatim he
said that
i i that was the number one thing on his
list so he said a bunch of things
said a lot of things can get us in
trouble yes targeting
a specific racial group that he is a
part of that's over that's all i'm going
to say
over over character over cultural
behaviors that exist upon among other
races that's the issue
right now you can argue when it came to
don lemon
that they were saying like you know don
lemon was talking specifically about his
community
but if you stripped if you just took the
words
and put them on any other platform you'd
get banned
outright yeah i suppose you can say don
lemon is speaking from experience
that's why i was acceptable back then
but he was saying bill o'reilly doesn't
go far enough yeah bill o'reilly
actually if we're gonna get into the
details he was the one who was talking
about
what terry was talking about yeah how
the family
the family unit is really important and
we need to really glorify the family
unit because people are falling out and
then
they don't have that structure they
don't have that that solid rock of what
a family can give to people
and uh then then he was like oh that's
not far enough
yeah then he was like i'm gonna well so
so here's what i want to bring this up
because there's a meme
it's a photo i i guess it's a kind of
meme check out this photo it's uh i
don't know where it's from
but it's you recognize it uh for those
are listening it is the revolution is
the black lives matter revolution fist
strangling the gadsden rattlesnake and
it says we
will tread this is amazing to me because
you know when i when i showed this to my
friends who are pro black lives matter
lefties yeah
they said that doesn't mean they're
authoritarians
and i said what do you think it means
and they said the gadsden flag is used
by racists
so they're just pointing out that you
know they're going to stop racism
how does that make sense it doesn't it's
an excuse right
it's it's them being like let me try and
figure out how to justify this
based on what we saw from joe jorgensen
you can really start to understand the
differences between
like the core of what it means for
libertarianism versus authoritarianism
saying we will tread it's it's literally
a part of what they do they say we must
do this we must be active we must tell
people they have to do this we must
police we must cancel culture
we must do all these things we will
police we will shut you down
yeah they say there's another one that's
an anarchist flag and
it's a mongoose eating a snake saying i
tread where i please
again overtly authoritarian i don't i
don't it's it's amazing to me how these
people fly
the colors red and black which is the
symbol for uh anarchism and labor i
think
yet they're overtly authoritarian this
is not anarchism
it's like it's fascism well borderline
they're getting there so the thing about
fascism is that there's a kind of
traditionalism associated with it
okay but the core of fascism and the
black lives matter fist is the exact
same thing
so for those that are not familiar the
fascists
is a symbol of fascism and it is a
bundle of sticks with like an axe it's a
weapon
and the idea was that all of those
sticks tied together made a more
powerful weapon
the black lives matter fist originated
my i could be wrong about this but it's
it's from the spanish civil war
where you saw the rise of communism and
fascism the whole idea between the two
groups was that we are stronger with
unity
and so the revolution fist was each
individual finger
coming together to be strong that's why
they would hold up their fist
and and so fascism specifically fell
among certain groups that were
considered to be
more it was like tradition versus
progress that was like really the
difference
i think if you look at it now of course
ask a story and they'll give you way
more nuance in this conversation
but if you look at the current
understanding of fascism versus
authoritarian communism
or the far left the people who are
you know as they describe far-right
authoritarian believe in traditional
family structures they believe in
a wife you know being home to raise the
kids things like that
they want it they want the good old days
stuff like that if you look at the far
left they want to destroy the family
structure
and they want complete hardcore
progressivism destroying
old traditions down with the patriarchy
is like one of the top on the right
i think that's a good movement that's
actually a really good uh easy way to
explain it
the far left says no patriarchy and
fascism says patriarchy but they're both
authoritarian structures
that's why i think people often say
they're fascists
because they do so much of the same
thing in fact
there is a famous anthropologist
associated with occupy wall street who
said
a certain sect to the left gaining
prominence has adopted fascistic
philosophies to to gain power
and one of those philosophies is quote
there is no truth but power
and that's what we're seeing now so when
you look at them flying a flag saying we
will tread
think about what's that what that means
we are going to take an action against
you
then take a look at what joe jorgensen
said we must be actively anti-racist
and you look at what anti-racism means
specifically
that you must take action to end racial
inequities
she is literally saying we all must
engage in an action against
other people's beliefs asserting her
more moral authority
that there's another big a piece to this
like i i i got to tell you man i'm
obsessed with the fact that they tweeted
this out
because i i politically fall in the
libertarian side of things though i'm
not overtly
real like realistically when it comes to
policy i'm not i wouldn't consider
myself to be a libertarian
liberal but telling someone
that their ideas are wrong is moral
authoritarianism
yep straight up if i said you're wearing
a muse
tattoos tattoos are wrong and i will
actively resist
all tattoos and i will fight like oh
whoa whoa
i'm gonna let you do your thing you know
what i mean i like my tattoos uh
you know what i have my opinions about
uh
i don't know veganism it's a good it's a
it's a good one
sure and i don't care if you choose to
eat whatever you want i don't care
i'm i'm a very libertarian vegan and
they're they're authoritarian vegans
yeah i can't stand them
i can't stand those they piss me off
it's like
you can't shove ideology down people's
throats it doesn't work now imagine
if you heard someone say we must be
actively anti-carnivore that's like whoa
whoa don't tell people what they have to
eat what they can or can't eat you know
right that's ridiculous
that's crazy the libertarian so that's
not going to change anything that's
going to make people want to go out and
and i don't know most people don't even
hunt themselves you know more
more respect to obviously the people
that do hunt for themselves but you know
it's like you can't expect the world to
just change
same with like fossil fuels it's like
the world runs on fossil fuels right now
we can't just like you were talking
about greta's like end fossil fuels
and it's like how dare you right you
know
we can't just turn the turn the switch
off the society would crumble apart and
we would all probably starve i get in a
year
i just i just i can't even you hear that
yeah i can't
literally i can't literally literally
literally
there was uh i see this facebook post
from basically
every single lefty friend i have where
they're like why are we trying to reopen
businesses
just pay the businesses and i'm like oh
these uninformed poor naive children
could you imagine that's the true
pandemic that's going on in this country
like the little kids ignorance yeah but
i mean
humans you know what i think it is i
don't know if it was you mentioning this
but
uh it's people have access to speak they
have these platforms now yeah so
yesterday marcellus wiley was was
originally sailing
saying it so now i was echoing it out
yeah ignorant people
have always existed absolutely everybody
is ignorant to a certain degree
it's true that some people are more
knowledgeable than others and in fact
some people are more
intelligent in terms of like their
ability to understand and and
you know break things down and rebuild
today
because of social media we have leveled
the playing field which is good in many
many ways
because it upsets the power structure it
was a problem
when our media was controlled by people
for the sake of you know just because
they were wealthy yeah
and it was like we we we had a better
system in america than we've had in a
long time because class used to be based
on your birth
now we literally had upward mobility
with with you know the rise of
you know this new world but you still
had people born into wealth so class
still existed and it was still mostly
about
you know if you wanted a job and this is
still true for the big news outlets
i would say the overwhelming majority of
the people who work for mainstream media
come from very wealthy families or
relatively wealthy families yeah they
got to try to maintain that control
so also here's how it works in in new
york if you want to get a job the new
york times
you have to do some kind of low paid
internship used to be unpaid
who can afford to live in new york for
10 bucks an hour nobody
exactly unless your parents pay your
bills that's true so this means that
poor people
never get into these positions but
this also means and and it's also
important to say just because you're
rich doesn't mean you're smart
so there was a tendency of people who
were educated to work at these outlets
but
now we have access to the internet every
single
person no matter how stupid or smart
they are has the same access
now there's some good news here
meritocracy smart people
and well a combination of smart and hard
work
and your voice will be louder than many
others but it is hard to rise above
when you are surrounded by a bunch of
really dumb people
and now what do we get man and they're
clustering up too
so you get those dumb people that have
this platform called the internet
and they blast something out there and
then you get all those other ignorant
people that also don't really understand
things
but it kind of it proves their point
they're like yeah that proves my point
i'm gonna shout it out and then it goes
to another circle of ignorant people
and then it just spreads the ignorance
around yep
so then what do we end up seeing
facebook has devolved into a place
where stupid people screenshot tweets
for half-baked political ideas and then
just post them
or just pass along like memes
that have stats on them yeah like i saw
one today
about trump's approval rating someone
was posting it up
you know it's like it's at an all-time
low and i'm
i'm like where'd that info come from i
don't know
no no response at all and i'm like hmm
do some digging sure enough it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't real and i'm like this
is
this is where you all are getting your
news it's embarra you're an
embarrassment
you're you're an embarrassment i can't
believe you're my friend it's exactly
like this conversation we've had several
times
where we mentioned you know some dude on
twitter it was a yang supporter
when i was talking about if the economy
grinds to a halt and no
products are being made then what do you
do with the money anyway
the food comes from the store tim
exactly the food comes from the store
look grows on the shelf like when you
were a little kid
and your parents just came with stuff as
far as you could tell
they could just have anything they
wanted and i think it's funny because
like
little kids really do this mentality
that when i'm an adult
i'm gonna have like three playstations
and i'm gonna eat nothing but cookie
dough
like they all the things they wish they
could have and they want they think
parents can just
get and then they get older and they
realize like what's all this other stuff
i got to deal with
taxes no one taught me taxes
yeah seriously why why aren't we taught
taxes that's a good question why is that
not a class and
also everyone deals with taxes you have
to pay taxes
why why don't we get taught how to
understand them what they
what they go towards what is going on
well that that brings me some reforms
you know that brings me to this meme
oh this meme there's a meme no you know
what before we move on yeah it's great
i'm not really moving
yeah yeah no it's too yeah it's great i
i just don't want to lose this
um thought it's it's people what
really annoys me is that if you disagree
on one thing
it's like suddenly they've put you in
this bracket that you disagree with
every single thing that they believe and
that is another thing it's not just
ignorance
it's it's the allowance or the
disallowance of
not letting anybody if they disagree
with one thing
you you suddenly now you don't agree
with me at all so you're just the enemy
and you know it's more of this division
yeah man they're dividing us
it's ridiculous and you're driving a
conversation but they want the anger
right they want the anger and you've
already been put in this bracket of
you you don't agree with me with one
little tiny minor thing
so civil conversations gone you can't
even have a conversation with them
anymore it's just
you disagree with every single thing i
say did you just say all lives matter
oh so you're a racist and you think
black lives don't matter and it's like
no
no no one thinks that they're they're
trying to tell you
it's two people trying to convince each
other that the sky is blue
that's that's what i'm seeing it's like
lives
in general really don't matter
we're all dust we're all gonna die
that's that's a reality like i've seen a
lot of death
in my life i've been around a lot of
close people to me have died so i've
seen it
a lot of people don't even see it so
when that when it does happen to them
they they the emotions flare and if
they're not
you know sound in a sound place then it
just flares out of control
some of these people take this to a dark
place though and it makes them negative
negative nihilists i call it okay people
who believe
that you know what that's this is it it
doesn't matter i won't be alive to see
it so why bother
yeah i once had a conversation with a
hardcore anti-sjw person
someone i know back from occupy wall
street who used to go on twitter and
just rag on me
like and i was like why why is this
person attacking me on twitter all the
time i don't get it
and we both had like comparable
followings the time and so one day
through the fact that i mean we're in
similar circles
like during occupy wall street yeah we
ended up at the same place and we had a
conversation
and it turned out that this individual
was actually incredibly intelligent
and we had a conversation about liberty
freedom rights
and we 100 agreed on everything
even philosophy and i was like wow so
why is it that i'm all about helping
you know trying to inform people let
them make the right choices and live
freely
and you're all about you know destroying
the system
and this person told me i take
sort of this nihilistic understanding of
the universe in a positive direction
that meaning is meaning the only meaning
that exists is the meaning we give
our existence that means i can't tell
you the meaning of life
but i do know that i will do my best to
help you
fulfill your existence so it's like i've
chosen what my meaning is
yeah make your life matter this other
person prove it matters
right so it's like you make your own
meaning almost the other person said
it's it's pointless
to even go that far why wouldn't it be
more fun just to watch the whole thing
burn to the ground
so this is somebody who right now is
still prominent okay you know i believe
writing books
published in major papers pretending to
care about racism
who told me explicitly i just want to
see it all burn because it's funny
literally the joker yeah and i was like
that's sad to me
that's evil like you you know what
you're doing
and my thing is like how can i make more
people feel good and your thing is how
can i cause more suffering
i'm not exaggerating it was literally
like but isn't it more fun just to watch
it all like break apart and collapse
right and and you know this is another
thing it's like people
when when someone says all lives matter
it suddenly
it's like they think well you don't
believe that there's bad people out
there then
oh yeah is that it's like no no everyone
knows that there's bad people
that exist there's evil humans people
people are
can be terrible we look at the history
of human beings
that that is not i mean it's not
arguable
like we know it you know slavery is
terrible
you know and it's going on today right
now across the globe it's happening
they're building your computers
you know it's like it exists but this is
the ignorance of these people you're
right
the and the ones who actually know they
they they create
stupid like it's sophistry man
there's people who are smart enough to
argue in favor of their fractured
ideology
to give stupid people what they think is
a rebuttal which isn't
that that comic i can reference yet you
live in society oh
you know the peasant saying we should
improve society somewhere it's like
if if you're talking about improving
society while actively whipping someone
that's a better that's a
better version of that comic right it's
like no dude you want to improve society
put the whip down
but i'm more effective with my whip the
slaves they keep working
right that's literally what they're
doing i want to improve society
yeah for you and the other you know
people with whips
but not for the people who are doing the
labor they pretend
it's it's it's a game which brings me
now to the and ignore
specifics too they ignore they ignore
anything that doesn't fit in their
little hallway of
what their their life um perspective is
they're just like oh it doesn't fall
into this then shh that doesn't exist
i want to show you some memes yeah go
forward because the libertarian party
this year at least is uh oof that's boat
sinking
so first you have the gadsden flag which
i'm sure most of you are familiar with
it says don't tread on me
and people have made memes mocking them
and i think they're all very funny i
don't care if you think they're right or
wrong this one i thought was funny i i
chose this one because you mentioned
taxes or whatever yeah it is funny
though and it's we're not taught
you know no one's taught how to do
tactics no you gotta figure it out on
your own it's like why wouldn't we want
people to know about it
it's a sad snake crudely drawn
that says i'm too stupid to understand
taxation
clearly they're trying to make fun of
libertarians who don't like taxes
i don't care if you agree with they're
not it's a funny picture that's the
point
you can have we're allowed to live with
things this one i really love
this one is uh i dedicate to sargon of
akkad
it's it's a it's a fancy looking snake
with a cane and a top hat of some sort
saying i do say mind where you walk old
chap
i love it that's a great one but what
i'm really getting at is while there are
many jokes
i specifically requested the opposite of
this and it's a snake being stepped on
we begin to see the complete and total
degradation
of you know the libertarian party which
many of you may be familiar with these
memes first of all this one's funny it's
a lego don't tread on me that i
definitely won't
next we have no step on snack this was
one of the memes that went around don't
try it on me no step on snack it's funny
haha
then we got steppent and it's a squiggly
line and then finally
don't this is where i think the
libertarian party is at right now
yep like don't don't what i don't know
it just doesn't even make sense but
welcome to uh
whatever this year is it could not get
crazier i don't know if like oh don't
attempt
don't tempt 2020. okay okay hold on
please maybe halfway through you think
it couldn't get crazy i don't know maybe
we're over the bell curve man
and we're gonna calm down i would love
to believe that i would like to think
that
actually i think if you if you
if you look at it the bell curve is the
beginning of the year we got gradual
craziness
then it got really crazy really really
fast but the
but the far side is is the level of
craziness is increasing
that's the bell curve is low craziness
maximum craziness
and now we're going down the roller
coaster while specific instances
the volume of crazy moments will
decrease the severity of the crazy will
increase
great thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode
you